this is Capitol TV
greetings citizens of Panem and welcome
to district 6 my name is Justine ezarik
and I'm a district liaison to the
Capitol as a part of the transportation
hub for our nation we build everything
from hovercraft to high speed trains to
tactical vehicles for our Nova
peacekeepers today I have the privilege
of showing you the capabilities of one
of these high powered machines to tell
us more I'm joined by master engineer
Garrick thank you it's an honor to serve
the capital the sj7 peacekeeper assault
transport is a state-of-the-art military
vehicle capable of deploying assets to
any hostile environment well it's
certainly impressive tell us more the SJ
sevens advanced suspension can handle
any terrain with ease the powertrain
outputs 827 brake horsepower from a
liquid-cooled Grantham 12 engine
the windows are equipped with 70
millimeter bulletproof glass the armor
can withstand high-caliber small arms
fire shrapnel and Explosives up to a k5
rating the V hull design protects
passengers even if a detonation occurs
directly beneath the vehicle but I
suggest we climb aboard and experience
the vehicle firsthand
thank you for your attention citizens we
hope you enjoyed watching one of the
many ways District six contributes to
our great nation love your labor take
pride in your task our future is in your
hands and don't forget to register for
updates from Capitol TV it's mandatory